eeuu lanzó este jueves una advertencia a
rusia sobre sus acciones intimidatorias
en ucrania tras movimientos de tropas
rusas en la frontera nuestra
preocupación está en las escaladas y
agresiones rusas en el este de ucrania
por supuesto nos preocuparía cualquier
intento de la federación rusa de
intimidar a sus vecinos ya nuestros
socios ucrania es por supuesto uno de
ellos
imágenes en las redes sociales han
sugerido en efecto que rusia ha estado
trasladando grandes cantidades de
vehículos blindados y otros equipos a
las regiones que limitan con un gran ya
en reacción el presidente ucraniano
acusó a moscú de tratar de crear una
atmósfera de amenaza
moscú debe cesar la escalada militar y
reafirmar inmediata e incondicionalmente
su compromiso con un acuerdo político y
diplomático y un régimen de alto al
fuego como respuesta a rusia subrayó que
el movimiento de tropas solo está
garantizando la seguridad de sus
fronteras sin embargo agregó que una
grave escalada del conflicto
más podría destruir a ucrania a juzgar
por la información publicada por los
medios de comunicación la mayoría de los
militares ucranianos comprende la
fatalidad de cualquier acción que
conduzca a un conflicto candente espero
que no sean incitados por los políticos
que a su vez sean incitados por
occidente y su líder
eeuu con sus rutas política con nieve
está inmerso en un conflicto con los
separatistas respaldados por moscú desde
2014 tras la tregua de 2020 el conflicto
en el este de ucrania se reavivó desde
enero y ha registrado varios
enfrentamientos armados que han causado
la muerte de 19 soldados ucranianos
dicha tensión provocó el pronunciamiento
este jueves de la unión europea al
recordar que no reconoce ni reconocerá
la anexión ilegal de la península de
crimea por rusia